[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Frédéric debuche
conservateur du musée de 5 de la ville
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
commissaire de l'exposition Space Age on
va parler aujourd'hui bonjour bonjour
alors le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines propose tout
au long de l'année des expositions et
des événements quels sont les ambitions
justement du musée au quotidien alors le
musée de la vitre travaille sur
plusieurs missions parallèlement c'est à
la fois un musée de valorisation du
territoire en tant qu'enseigne ville
nouvelle notamment
donc avec un volet axé sur la
valorisation du patrimoine architectural
urbain artistique paysagers il y a
notamment dans ce programme un vol
important en matière de restauration
d'art public puisque la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est
propriétaire de 40 oeuvres d'art urbain
qu'il faut entretenir et restaurer
et parallèlement comme tout musait le
musée de la ville est un musée avec des
collections et notamment une collection
phare enfin c'est pas la seule mais
c'est effectivement la plus importante
du musée en nombre qui est la collection
design et mode de vie qui est riche de
3000 objets et c'est une collection qui
sur laquelle sont notamment fondés nos
expositions temporaires donc ça c'est
une exposition justement qui est qui est
tout au long de l'année qui est à
découvrir tout au long de l'année au
musée de la ville alors pas tout au long
de l'année puisqu'elle a été inaugurée
le 8 février celle-ci dure jusque début
juillet et à partir de septembre une
autre exposition des buts qui va
s'arrêter en janvier en propose en fait
deux expositions à l'année c'est une
manière de faire tourner nos collections
qui sont voilà comme tout musait
beaucoup de nos collections sont en
réserve et les expositions temporaires
c'est le le meilleur moyen pour pour les
montrer alors la culture est un domaine
important pour la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
est-ce que vous estimez que le Musée de
la Ville propose justement assez de
assez d'exposition à cet événements
culturels sur le territoire alors on
essaye de de proposer à la fois des
événements au musée dans nos murs en
l'occurrence ces expositions et la
programmation qui qui gravite autour de
ces expositions comme comme les visites
les ateliers les conférences et puis
aussi certains événements comme la nuit
du musée qui aura lieu bientôt au mois
de au mois de mai mais le musée
travaille aussi et sur l'ensemble du
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines avec
différentes opérations de valorisation
du patrimoine architectural et urbain
alors c'est vrai que pour les événements
qui sont en dehors du musée il s'agit
davantage de d'action orientées en
faveur de la valorisation du patrimoine
et donc les collections mais on a aussi
des projets néanmoins pour pour faire
tourner les nos collections de musée sur
les territoires et pour les faire
accueillir dans différentes communes de
la de la communauté d'agglomération si
vous êtes invité aujourd'hui c'est pour
parler de l'exposition Space Age quand
la conquête spatiale inspire le design
pouvez-vous nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur cette exposition et surtout
pourquoi cette exposition alors c'est
une exposition qui qui est proposée
parce qu'elle rentre
en ligne droite dans la spécificité de
notre collection design et mode de vie
notre collection design est surtout axée
sur les années
60-7080
c'est une collection qui est aussi très
orientée sur l'univers de la maison on y
trouve une palette très large d'objets
du mobilier des luminaires des nouvelles
technologies
des arts de la table des textiles même
des jouets et le Space Age et justement
un terme qui qualif
le style de certains objets qui ont été
produits à cette époque dans les années
60-70 notamment encore au début des
années 80 et qui ont été produits dans
le contexte de l'exploration spatiale ou
enfin l'exploration spatiale continue
aujourd'hui mais plus exactement dans
les débuts de l'exploration spatiale qui
commence dans les années 50
avec le lancement du premier satellite
artificiel par les Russes le fameux
Spoutnik qui se prolonge dans les années
60 avec le premier homme dans l'espace
et puis en point de
culminant le premier pas de l'homme sur
la Lune en 1969 et donc ce
c'est début de la conquête spatiale
ont beaucoup fasciné à la fois les
populations mais aussi les créateurs les
designers les architectes et ceci ce
sont emparés de à la fois de la réalité
de la conquête spatiale mais aussi de
tout l'imaginaire qui pouvait graviter
autour de la conquête spatiale pour
créer des objets en lien
de près ou de loin avec avec cette
thématique en fait l'exposition met en
avant justement les objets du quotidien
en tout cas de de l'époque en lien avec
cette conquête spatiale est-ce que
finalement ça signifie que chaque
décennie chaque événement inspire
finalement le design oui alors
le design et la conjonction un peu comme
l'architecture ou comme là de plusieurs
facteurs mais dans le design on a la
fois la rencontre
de la société de ce qu'elle est un
moment donné de l'histoire il y a aussi
les techniques les
les courants artistiques et tout ça
convergent à randonnée vers
un même endroit et ce qui amène à avoir
des des styles qui sont identifiés en
fonction des périodes et qui répondent à
différents à différents besoins et
indifférente effet de effet de monnaie
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on qu'on peut
facilement dater les objets parce que
c'est c'est différent facteurs se
réunissent à un moment donné et puis à
une génération suivante on passe on
passe à autre chose et le spéciège alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
spécial est une dénomination finalement
relativement récente alors déjà à
l'époque dans les années 50 on parlait
du spaceage mais en tant que coeur
spatiale comme voilà lié à l'exploration
spatiale mais pas appliquée un principe
de style ou de définition
d'un courant artistique c'est après coup
on a fini par qualifier les objets qui
étaient
inspirés par par l'espace de de ce
spécial mais finalement voilà c'était
pas revendiqué comme tel à l'époque les
termes étaient différents alors
justement quels sont les spécificités
les objets qu'on peut qu'on peut
retrouver un peu un peu anecdotique
anecdotique pardon de cette période
alors c'est justement le l'objet de
l'exposition on essaye à travers elle de
de cerner et de qualifier ce qu'on ce
qui peut être considéré comme Space Age
et on aborde donc l'exposition à travers
différentes thématiques on se rend
compte par exemple que le que le les
formerontes sont très spécifiques de
de ce mouvement alors la forme ronde
parce que elle renvoie à la fois par
exemple le premier Spoutnik qui était
une petite boule en aluminium la forme
ronde renvoie aussi à la forme de la
planète que ce soit la lune enfin ou des
planètes en général
la Lune la Terre etc
et la forme ronde renvoie aussi par
exemple au casque du cosmonaute on a
d'ailleurs dans l'exposition une télé
JVC qui date de 1970 donc qui était
conçu vraiment au moment de la de la
mission Apollon quand les Américains
lancent
cette mission pour conquérir la lune et
on a une télé qui ressemble vraiment à
un casque de cosmos voilà donc on essaie
comme ça par différents biais de
caractériser le Space il y a une autre
brique sur
sur la couleur blanche par exemple voilà
c'est aussi alors qu'un objet soit blanc
pour qu'il soit spécial mais ça
participe de ces caractéristiques il y a
aussi tout ce qui relève du de ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier la haute technologie
et donc ça se traduit en matière de
design par exemple dans l'emploi de
matériaux en métal
dans des finitions assez assez
clinquantes comme l'acier l'acier
brossette etc l'aluminium parce que le
métal renvoie une sorte de modernité de
de nouvelles technologies et on associe
facilement à la conquête de l'espace qui
est par la définition par définition à
l'époque euh le le summum de la
modernité de et du progrès scientifique
et vous organiser également des des
parcours jeux en famille donc c'est une
exposition qui se veut de toute façon
familiale il y a de la découverte il y a
de l'histoire mais c'est surtout aussi à
une découverte familiale oui bien sûr
alors c'est c'est notre public alors de
toute façon je dise naturellement tout
tous les publics il y a dans cette
exposition déjà beaucoup à voir donc
sans sans sans apport de texte enfin il
y a un texte en support mais voilà on
peut déjà se contenter de la
contemplation des objets il y a un
parcours effectivement qui est adapté
pour pour les enfants et qui donne aussi
un éclairage un petit peu différent sur
ou complémentaire sur sur le Space Age
et c'est aussi une exposition qu'on peut
tout à fait voir en famille qui est
intergénérationnel puisque les les les
parents ou les grands-parents peuvent
aussi expliquer aux plus jeunes certains
objets c'est donc une position à
retrouver en famille jusqu'en juillet
merci beaucoup Frédéric Dubuche d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensation pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site musée de la ville sqy.fr et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]